from time to time I like to keep it real
loose around here and just take well a
little question and answer segment with
my audience you know it's a great way
for me to get closer to my fans so I
thought we'd try it right now in a
little segment I'm calling all right
this should be fun
who's got a question how about yes you
yeah well I was gonna ask you some of
your favorite guests are but I got to be
honest right now I just want to know
what the hell happened in that lake
house yeah I'm sorry as the name of the
segment clearly states I will answer any
question except anything related to what
happened at the lake house that one
summer okay everything you need to know
about that incident can already be found
in the police report I would say Martin
Short is the best guest that I could
have consistently he's terrific next
question two questions um
I love carpool karaoke and what happened
at the lake house yeah okay first part
wasn't actually a question and carpool
karaoke that's James Corden yeah okay a
second part while definitely a question
was about the lake house which I'm not
at liberty to discuss so I'd also like
to add apropos of nothing I have an
extremely common blood type just
something few people to know next
question please
yeah sir hi um are there any celebrities
you hang out with outside the show yeah
sure Kevin Nealon is a great old friend
of mine sometimes we get together and
hang out was he with you at the lake
house hold on a second yeah I was
mistaken I've never met Kevin Nealon
next question just curious what's the
statute of limitations for false
imprisonment and wrongful death okay in
New York state false imprisonment is one
year wrongful death is two years from
the time of death I didn't specify New
York State is that where the lake house
is there next question keeping in mind
I've already made my position very clear
about the lake house what the hell
happened at that lake house why my
answers now goddamn it Andy we know
that's you that's pathetic
let me look like a sick Colonel Sanders
[Applause]
let me just say this most lake houses
are very old and full of all kinds of
hazards like faulty wiring loose
banisters leaky gas lines a lot of
accidents can happen in Lake houses
including things that might even seem
implausible to a jury like a canoe fire
or a deadly owl attack all right next
question yes hi do you recognize this
blood-soaked toupee I'm sorry is this
about the lake house I don't know is it
okay next question oh for God's sakes no
no somebody else somebody else please
yes I I have several questions for you
mr. O'Brien great what's your name sir
detective Dennis McDaniel Saratoga
Police Department okay that's all the
time we have for tonight
[Applause]